en este vídeo vamos a hablar de
anisotropías de a magnéticas y son
palabras bastante rebuscadas hemos
hablado del día magnetismo en vídeos
anteriores y usamos la corriente en una
espiral de alambre como analogía si la
corriente se mueve en esta dirección en
una espiral de alambre la ahí representa
la corriente se crea un campo magnético
exactamente en el centro de esta espiral
el campo magnético
apunta directamente hacia abajo y
conforme nos alejamos del centro puedo
agregar unas cuantas líneas de campo
magnético y no hicimos esto en vídeos
anteriores
mientras te acercas a la inspira por
dentro de la expira el campo magnético
apuntará hacia abajo pero afuera de la
espiral el campo magnético apuntará
hacia arriba y lo mismo pasa en este
lado el campo magnético está apuntando
hacia abajo por dentro
y el campo magnético apunta hacia arriba
fuera de la espiral estamos hablando de
la corriente estamos pensando en cargas
positivas moviéndose pero eso no es lo
que está pasando sabemos que en realidad
son los electrones en los que se están
moviendo y las cargas en movimiento
crean un campo magnético los electrones
se están moviendo en una dirección
opuesta a la manera en la que definimos
la corriente
tenemos densidad electrónica moviéndose
de esta manera y obtenemos un campo
magnético si pensamos en el benceno el
del seno tiene 6 electrones que por aquí
arriba está el benceno así que ahora
identifiquemos a los electrones pin 2 4
y 6 y si sometemos al benceno a un campo
magnético aplicado aquí está nuestro
campo magnético aplicado b 0 está
apuntando hacia arriba esos 6 electrones
pide el benceno van a circular para
crear un campo magnético inducido y
déjame continuar dibujando una
representación de los electrones
del benceno circulando los electrones
que van en esta dirección y si los
electrones están yendo en esta dirección
entonces sabemos que el campo magnético
inducido estaría apuntando hacia abajo
aquí precisamente en el centro el campo
magnético inducido estaría apuntando
hacia abajo el campo magnético inducido
apunta hacia abajo y mientras te alejas
del centro nuevamente podemos dibujar
más líneas de campo magnético y mientras
te acercas a la espiral del anillo de
benceno nuevamente adentro del anillo
el campo magnético apunta hacia abajo y
fuera del anillo del campo magnético
apuntará hacia arriba
hablemos del campo magnético
experimentado por este protón
el protón experimenta el campo magnético
aplicado v0 pero también siente este
campo magnético inducido que está en la
misma dirección que el campo magnético
externo así que esta es la dirección del
campo magnético inducido afuera de la
espiral así que para obtener el campo
magnético efectivo que siente este
protón tienes que sumar el campo
magnético inducido al campo magnético
aplicado para encontrar el campo
magnético efectivo
afuera del anillo obtenemos un campo
magnético mayor obtenemos una diferencia
mayor entre los estados de espín alfa y
beta en términos de energía y una
diferencia más grande en términos de
energía significa la absorción de una
frecuencia mayor y por ende obtienes un
desplazamiento químico mayor y entonces
el protón en el benceno tiene un
desplazamiento químico de
aproximadamente 7.27 partes por millón
así que esto es solo para cualquier
protón cualquier tipo de anillo de
benceno aquí tu intervalo general será
de 6.5 a 8 y hay varias moléculas que
muestran este efecto de manera exagerada
y veamos una de ellas como sabemos que
este efecto es incluso verdadero si veo
esta molécula tenemos un anillo gigante
aquí así que déjame ir alrededor de él
para que veas el contorno de este anillo
gigante un anillo mucho más grande que
el benceno tenemos muchos electrones
espín más electrones piqué en el benceno
por lo que solo resaltaré a algunos de
ellos
8 y así sucesivamente puedes ver que
tenemos enlaces simples y dobles
alternados en esta molécula y entonces
si pones a esta molécula en un campo
magnético externo vamos a tener la misma
situación que en el benceno así que
pensemos en estos protones de aquí
adentro 6 protones internos si ves al
diagrama para el benceno si tienes un
campo magnético externo aplicado ve 0
justo en el centro del anillo los
protones internos se experimentan un
campo magnético inducido que va hacia
abajo que se opone al campo magnético
externo así que continuemos dibujando
eso aquí
si aplicamos un campo magnético externo
de cero los protones en el interior
tienen un campo magnético inducido
causado por el movimiento de esos
electrones y el campo magnético inducido
se opone al campo magnético aplicado y
entonces el campo magnético efectivo
sentido por esos protones internos es
más pequeño
entonces obtenemos un menor campo
magnético efectivo un campo magnético
más pequeño significa una diferencia en
energía menor entre el estado de spin
alfa y el beta debido a eso tenemos una
señal de frecuencia más baja y un
desplazamiento químico más bajo y el
desplazamiento químico para estos seis
protones internos resulta ser menos dos
partes por millón piensa lo que quiere
decir eso menos 2 es menor que el tms si
volvemos aquí arriba el tms estaba en
cero por lo que el menos 2 sería a la
derecha pero no tenemos suficiente
espacio para mostrarlo en este
desplazamiento químico de aquí está
pasando el tms es un efecto bastante
exagerado
podemos ver a los protones afuera del
anillo también así que déjame resaltar
esos tenemos 12 protones afuera del
anillo ya que esos protones están afuera
del anillo el campo magnético inducido
está ahora en la misma dirección que el
campo magnético aplicado por lo tanto
obtenemos un campo efectivo mayor
sentido por uno de esos protones un
campo magnético más largo significa una
diferencia en energía mayor entre tus
estados de espn alfa y beta obtendrás
una señal de frecuencia más alta y un
desplazamiento químico más alto
el desplazamiento químico es de
aproximadamente 9 partes por millón así
que la diferencia dramática entre estos
desplazamientos químicos para estos
protones internos y externos demuestra
que tan poderoso puede ser este efecto
usemos este efecto para explicar el
desplazamiento de un protón en un enlace
triple así que si pensamos en un
acetileno aquí está un acetileno y si
buscar la señal para este protón
pensemos en el carbono al cual está
enlazado este carbono de aquí tiene
hibridación esp y en el vídeo anterior
hablamos del hecho de que un orbital con
hibridación esp tiene más caracteres que
uno con hibridación sp2 o sp3 y entonces
la densidad electrónica estará más
pegada a este carbono puedes pensar en
un carbono con hibridación esp siendo
más electro negativo que un carbono con
hibridación sp2 o sp3 así que la
densidad electrónica está más cerca a
este carbono de aquí
el cual pensarías que deslindar a este
protón y te dará un desplazamiento
químico más alto que un protón en un
doble enlace pero eso no es lo que
observamos el desplazamiento para este
protón resulta ser aproximadamente de 2
a 2.5 por lo que es de hecho un
desplazamiento químico más bajo que el
del protón en el doble enlace y veamos
si podemos explicar por qué si aplicamos
un campo magnético externo de 0 es
nuestro campo magnético externo aplicado
sabemos que causa que los electrones
fish y el cullen y si tenemos una
orientación vertical de nuestro
acetileno si la orientación de la
molécula importa si está orientada en
esta dirección los electrones iban a
circular de esta manera y de la misma
manera en la que hablamos con el benceno
si los electrones espín circulan de esta
manera obtenemos un campo magnético
inducido apuntando hacia abajo en esta
dirección de esta manera podemos dibujar
más líneas de campo magnético y piensa
en el campo magnético experimentado por
digamos este protón este protón está
sintiendo el campo magnético aplicado
pero también siente el campo magnético
inducido pero el campo magnético
inducido está en la dirección opuesta
del campo magnético aplicado puedes
dibujar el campo magnético inducido
oponiéndose al campo magnético aplicado
ese protón que circula y de hecho siente
un campo magnético efectivo menor aquí
si obtienes un campo magnético efectivo
menor estás disminuyendo la diferencia
de energía entre tu estado de espn alfa
y beta por lo que obtienes un
desplazamiento químico menor a lo
esperado debido a este efecto
eso es actualmente como explicamos el
desplazamiento químico algo alrededor de
2.5 para un protón en un enlace triple y
entonces este efecto es verdadero cada
vez que tienes electrones pi que pueden
circular cuando ponemos una molécula en
un campo magnético aplicado y entonces
podemos también utilizar esto para
explicar por ejemplo el protón en doble
enlace cierto aquí hay unos electrones
pib o el protón aquí lo tenemos al lado
de este carbón y lo de aquí así que
tenemos electrones vi aquí todas las
veces que tienes electrones pi se puede
presentar este efecto y como vimos puede
ser un efecto muy poderoso que realmente
afecta al desplazamiento químico